what I wanted to show you this time yes
is what we're gonna refer to as the Oh
spot which is further in and behind the
cervix this is the uterus by the way
this red balloon I thought there was a
lot all women had a balloon okay it's
like a party okay I'm sorry we're being
childish and now we're gonna be serious
again that's is that is that the only
way into it that way it's through the
vagina anything this is kind of far back
there your hand - oh so long fingers I I
have very big hands and long finger so
you all know that thank you
so you get your hand all the way back
there and then behind and stimulate that
area this is really far up
I think this is the lung at this point
baby okay so so what am I doing here
you're stimulating that area either
manually with your hand or with your
your lower genital part well that's a
long way well so hopefully it's long
enough
[Applause]
and
blow and get bigger okay forget the
balloon he's right you both think you're
right to forget the balloon because the
focus is not on universe you're right to
ask with the blue and get bagger because
nothing happened it's very important
that that the woman is aroused
you can't just reach this area by diving
right in it requires some stimulation
does she have to be awake okay it's
better if they're awake yeah so this is
called the Oh spot you know Mike a
cul-de-sac behind the cervix somebody's
not gonna be able to get my hand out of
this home with them thank you okay so
you go back there and what are you doing
back there you're you're stimulating
that area either with your hand or with
a erotic toy or with what I just
mentioned before which is hopefully
longing yes yes the the original
equipment we're all given which in this
case will more than
[Laughter]
you